digamos que estamos estudiando un país
que solamente vende manzanas es lo que
hace y su producto interno bruto en el
año 1
supongamos de mil pesos lo abrevió pips
y uno en el año 1 fue de 1000 pesos para
este país que solamente vende manzanas y
también sabemos que el costo de las
manzanas en ese año es de 50 centavos el
precio en el año 1 es de 50 centavos 50
centavos el kilo
y bueno digamos que ya pasó el año 1 y
también el año 2
así que ya también podemos calcular o
medir el producto interno bruto en el
año 2 digamos que éste fue de 1200 pesos
para el año 2 y el precio de las
manzanas en ese año fue de 55 centavos
el kilo 55 centavos el kilo así que
tengo una pregunta para ti la razón por
la cual calculamos el pib es para medir
la productividad del país y es verdad
que estamos midiendo en términos de
pesos pero nos interesan más más que
saber la cantidad de pesos nos interesa
más saber si el país fue productivo y si
así lo fue
cuanto fue productivo si solamente
observamos estos números del pib echar
un vistazo a estos 1000 contra estos
1200 observas que 1.206 20% más que
aquellos 1000 pesos del año 1 eso nos
dice que el producto interno bruto
creció por 20 por ciento más 20 por
ciento pero crees que eso sí representa
la productividad del país si será el
caso que el país en efecto produjo 20
por ciento más en bienes y una buena
pista para saber si este es el caso es
ver estos precios de aquí estos dos de
aquí porque algo del producto interno
bruto en realidad pudo haber sido
incrementado sólo por este precio y
bueno en realidad eso no significa que
el país haya o no sido más productivo la
cantidad de manzanas que produce el país
es lo que da la productividad del país
una manera de pensarlo aquí voy a
dibujar un pequeño diagrama en este eje
va a representar la cantidad y este otro
eje representará el precio y con este
diagrama si yo quiero saber el pib para
el año 1 aquí tendría yo el precio de
las manzanas para dicho año claro
solamente uso manzanas porque simplifica
las cosas acá tengo la cantidad de
manzanas
y este cuadro este cuadro esta área
representa el pib para el año 1 pib para
el año 1 luego el pib para el año 2
sería el precio de las manzanas en el
año 2 así que más o menos por aquí 55
centavos por por la cantidad de manzanas
en el año 2 más o menos por acá así que
el producto interno bruto es el área es
el área de todo esto
ese es el pib para el año 2 y si
queremos encontrar las diferencias entre
los dos tipos sería la diferencia en las
áreas sería esta área que estoy aquí
esto que estoy aquí coloreando de azul
es la diferencia basándonos en los
números basándonos en los números el
área que estoy coloreando la diferencia
entre el pib 1 y el pib de del año 2
este azul representa esos 200 pesos 200
pesos a diferencia entonces estos
representan los 200 pesos de diferencia
cuando lo observas bien ves que esos 200
pesos algo de ellos es claramente por el
incremento en la cantidad que hubo pero
también mucho de ello es debido al
incremento que hubo en el precio así que
si en realidad
vamos a ver cuanto más productividad
hubo en el país si quisiéramos medir el
pib en pesos se nos ocurre quizás
podríamos medir el pib del año 2 pero
con precios del año 1 así que si de
alguna manera pudiéramos multiplicar la
cantidad del año 2 por los precios del
año 1
entonces obtendríamos este rectángulo de
aquí este rectángulo de aquí y la
diferencia entre este y el año 1 nos
daría el pib y incrementado en precios
del año 1 dado por la cantidad y de
hecho eso es lo que en realidad nos
interesa nos interesa saber la
productividad total cuando pensamos en
producto interno bruto para un país
estamos pensando en qué tan productivo
fue el país en un determinado tiempo así
que intentemos averiguarlo con estos
números de aquí podemos averiguar la
cantidad del año 2 sólo con dividir el
pib por el precio es decir sólo con
dividir el área el área total del
rectángulo azul y dividiéndolo por el
precio nos dará la cantidad así que si
dividimos 1200 entre 55 saca de la
calculadora aquí está
a la cantidad de manzanas así que 1.200
1200 en 3.55 eso nos da 2 mil 181 que
voy a redondear es 2 mil 182 2 mil 182
es la cantidad en kilos de manzanas la
cantidad en el año 2 es de 2 mil 182
kilos de manzanas y bueno entonces el
pib del año 2 entre el precio del año 2
meda 2.182 y esta cantidad esta
respuesta multiplicada por el precio del
año 1 que son las manzanas estaban en 50
centavos el kilo por el precio del año 1
esto me da la cantidad de bueno lo hace
la calculadora de hecho por tendría que
hacer la cabeza pero pero veamos
es la respuesta por punto 5 me da esto
lo voy a redondear a 1.091 1.091 y de
hecho de esto este número es bastante
interesante 1.091 este número lo podemos
ver como el producto interno bruto el
pib el pib del año 2 del año 2 am lo
pongo de esta manera
es el pib del año dos ajustados precios
ajustado precios del año 1 ajustado a
precios del año 1 y lo bonito de este
asunto es que esto nos dice mira si los
precios se hubieran mantenido constantes
esto sería el pib esto sería el pip si
los precios no hubieran incrementado el
pib hubiera sido de 1.091 el cual
representa esta área rosa de aquí así
que ahora lo que tú podrías decir es si
los precios se hubieran mantenido
constantes el crecimiento en el pib
hubiera sido de 91 pesos agua o no de
291 ésta
a naranja esta área aquí naranja que es
el crecimiento real si los precios si
hubieran mantenido constantes a 91 pesos
de mil pesos en el pib a 1.091 esta área
de aquí es de 91 pesos que podemos
llamar crecimiento real crecimiento real
que realmente mide la productividad que
hubo en el país en ese año esto nos da
unas ideas bastante interesantes una de
ellas es medir el pib en el dinero del
año en curso
esto fue el pib del año 2 entonces fue
medido en dinero en precios del año 2 lo
podemos llamar el pib nominal el pib
nominal con precios del año 2 pib
nominal pibn nominal
entonces bueno todo esto esto de aquí
estoy aquí en donde se midió el pib del
año 2 en base a precios de otro año nos
permite ver el verdadero crecimiento de
productividad
vemos que la productividad creció por 9%
9% más en manzanas y a esto le llamamos
el pib real producto interno bruto real
pib
y le llamamos así porque nos da una
medida de la productividad real trata de
quitar trata de quitar el incremento de
los precios y bueno veremos en el futuro
claro quizás no sea un curso
introductorio pero en la práctica es
bastante difícil medir y tú sabes todo
ahora aquí están conmigo hablando
solamente de un producto manzanas pero
si hablamos de muchos muchos muchos
productos no sabes un buen de productos
muchísimos no es fácil saber cómo
ajustar con el precio no es asunto
sencillo pero los encargados de las
cuentas nacionales de ingreso si
intentan llevar todo esto controlado y
así ellos saben el verdadero crecimiento
real que hubo en un país